au cinéma le grenier à sel nous avons eu
un énorme coup de coeur pour le film
papicha de mounia meddour c'est un film
qui a eu pas mal de récompenses
notamment pour la réalisatrice et
l'actrice principale donc mounia meddour
la raisin triste elin à caudry l'actrice
principale
nous sommes à alger dans les années 90
donc les années sombres en algérie et le
personnage joué par l'ina à caudry elle
s'appelle nedjma ces tunnels à 18 ans
elle est étudiante et elle veut devenir
styliste
elle crée elle même ses propres rôles
dans ses propres vêtements dans le cadre
de la cité universitaire où aller et
s'est laissé la période effectivement où
l'extrémiste prendre l'ampleur et elle
décide de ne peut rien lâcher on suit
cette aventure qui est un petit peu
autobiographique puisque la réalisatrice
a été elle-même étudiante
a alger dans les années 90 on profite
aussi de toute la richesse d'alger le
langage le français arabe et je vous
conseille vraiment de venir le voir nous
l'avons donc en avant première le
vendredi 4 octobre à 20h45 et notre
deuxième coup de coeur c'est shawn la
ferme contre attaque donc les studios
aardman nous régale d'un
une science fiction et ses personnages
en pâte à modeler nous l'avons donc en
avant première dans le cadre de la
journée européenne du cinéma d'art et
essai ce sera le dimanche 13 octobre à
15 heures
[Musique]